an opener victor gonzalez
it's gonna be nice to see victor out
there this is something that could
happen in the playoffs if they have a
bullpen day or if they need an opener in
front of tony gonzalen or if they need
an open in front of dustin may that's
probably the role he's playing today i
think dustin may will end up getting the
bulk of the innings and we will see
victor gonzalez start out of the bullpen
taylor ward coming up right-handed
hitter open stance
swing and a miss by ward and one two
three first for victor gonzalez this is
patrick sandoval who's been back and
forth between the bullpen and the
rotation this season
and the lefty gets the start in the
season finale with a home run on friday
night he's got 14 total this season
career high in a normal year 21.
it's this one in the air to deep left
center field backy girls he's yet
another
lead off home run for any j collins
number 15 of the season
and the long ball weekend continues for
the dodgers against the angels it's a
lead off home run for aj pollock this is
just unbelievable a relentless onslaught
of power by the dodgers who have just
hit their
117th home run
and they take a one to nothing lead one
battery
time now for dustin may out of the
bullpen is 2-7-7 era top 10 in the
national league may on 1-2 adele open
stands the pitch swung on and missed
strike three back with the curveball so
you get gas
smoke up in your eyes and then a
breaking ball downstairs
i don't see him throwing a fastball
right now so hopefully us can take this
ball for ball four all right dave thanks
so much for your time this year and he
did there you go ball four good luck the
rest of the way all right
here's peterson three balls two strikes
sandoval delivers low ball four sandoval
walks the eight and nine hitters and now
full count on pollock who took him deep
the first time
he walked in and he's walked the bases
loaded and they're loaded up for seegers
looking for his first hit of this series
0 for 9. sandoval delivers and a slow
hit ground ball to second base throw the
second added second onto first double
play
so seeger bounces into the double play
barnes comes in to score
there's two out and a dodger two-nothing
lead
peterson's at third as turner steps in
turner pops it into shadow right field
on a very bright and sunny day the
shades down and the ball down and
turner's got an rbi hit to extend the
on bay streak like that oh my jared walt
retreating
into short right he drops the ball
in the score is peterson and the dodgers
take a three-nothing lead here's tim
award here's the 2-2 swung on and missed
strike three
ward is down on strike and for may his
third strikeout
the one-two pitch got him swinging you
know tiny struggles continue now joe
adele who struck out in his first at-bat
two from dustin may
chases for strike three and that's the
ending a lead off walk but then three
consecutive strikeouts and mays got five
total through three innings of work
and the dodgers have a three-run lead
jack peterson leads off this seventh
inning for the dodgers against
left-hander hobie milner
and bangs the first pitch by him into
center field for a lead off single
this might be off or not but i sure
would like to see the dodgers catch the
atlanta braves as far as runs scored and
have the lowest era and the most runs
scored josh setting the table to maybe
make that a possibility
a lead off home run from this man back
in the first inning aj pollock
fly to center field sending it down back
on to the warning track pollux hit his
second today
what a finish to the regular season for
angel pollock he's reached all four
times he's at two home runs 16 for the
year
a home run for aj pollock is second of
the day his 16th of the year and the
dodgers take a five to nothing lead
star gradual is now on in relief
greneral gets jones looking for the
first out of the eighth ho-hum 100.
fletcher is 0 for three a 2-2
i got a comebacker
snared by grouderal throws a fastball to
uh
[ __ ] hernandez at first one two three
the angels are done dodgers five number
two
jansen and oltani
at least luck doesn't feel like it plays
such a huge role to the bad goes
hernandez
that does it the dodgers finish off this
sprint of a regular season with the best
record in baseball at 43 and 17
60 games yes but the highest winning
percentage
since the 1909 pittsburgh pirates in the
national league the first team since the
1999 pirate story more than 70 of their
games